tuberculosis is the world's leading
infectious disease killer it's not covet
it was in 2020 and 2021 right but even
in 2022 it was not tuberculosis is a
killer that we don't even think about
anymore in the rich World it used to
kill a lot of us tuberculosis over the
last 200 years probably killed about a
billion people so everyone you know now
that's not true but a fourth of everyone
you knew in the 1800s died from killed
Doc Holiday we all know that if you if
you watch Wyatt Earp and Young Guns well
there you go yeah and yeah and it was a
disease but then came a peninsulin and
we basically got rid of it you know we
got we knew how to fix it and it's not
been a problem in rich countries it
still is a huge problem so it kills 1.4
million people in the poor part of the
world and this is mostly moms and dads
you know so it's middle-aged people
who've just got their own family we've
already educated them and then they die
that's not just a terrible tragedy for
those family but it also means that
there's less productivity in the in the
uh in the Nations which goes back to
your initial Point like how do you if
you're trying to not die of tuberculosis
you're like you want me to worry about
the climate and 2100 exactly dream on
yeah and so we need to get more
medication this is mainly a problem of
people actually taking one of the
reasons why it's really hard to get
people to take it is you need to take
the medication for four to six months
have you guys ever gotten like a two two
week uh you know uh uh peninsulin cure
and you need yeah I'm looking for a
two-week vacation Bjorn all right sorry
but I can't help you there but you know
it's hard to keep up doing when you when
you get well you know to keep
remembering to take it but these guys
actually have to take it for four or six
months and that's really hard so you
need apps you need to have sort of games
maybe tuberculosis and Anonymous where
you get together every week and say yes
I took my pills and that kind of so
there's a lot of ways to sort of engage
people in doing it because if they don't
they create multi-resistant tuberculosis
which is much worse and then we need to
find a lot more so we estimate about 10
billion sorry 10 million people get sick
every year but we only treat about six
million out of them and the four million
that both die but also pass on the
tuberculosis to new generations that
then go on and die so if we do this
it'll cost about six billion dollars but
we'll save about a million people every
year it turns again it's a it delivers
forty six dollars of social good for
every dollar spent so what we're
basically trying to say is there are
these 12 amazing things
in total they will cost 35 billion
dollars per year not trillion dollars
like you know aoc's uh solutions to
climate a very very small amount it will
save 4.2 million lives every year and it
will make the poor part of the world 1.1
trillion dollars richer every year it
will simply deliver an incredible amount
of good at very low cost and that's the
basic point you know so you asked what
are the biggest problems well here are
the best solutions for the world these
are very cheap they're incredibly
effective and you've never heard of them
they're not fun right they're not the
kind of thing that we talk about with
climate that makes us all anxious and
politicians can get you worried about
they just happen to be incredibly good
Solutions so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]